wassila tamzali et auteur militante
féministe d'algérie également été
ancienne avocate à la cour d'alger de 66
à 77 ex directrice des droits des femmes
à l'unesco à paris et auteur de plats de
livres les digues ou du maghreb une
femme en colère lettre d'alger aux
européens désabusés et quelques autres
éléments ont invité aujourd'hui mais on
va parler entre autres et surtout des
ateliers sauvage madame tamzali pont
jours bonjour bonjour et bienvenue à
radio canada l'idée des ateliers sauvage
comment est elle née et que sont ces
ateliers oui alors sauvage c'est en
pensant aux fleurs sauvages d'accord
voilà donc on reste dans la tendresse et
la beauté n'ont pas servi à la beauté
vous avez d'un côté oui mais la beauté
et souvent il ya de la violence dans la
beauté aussi d'accord d'accord donc les
ateliers sauvages sont nés de ma
rencontre avec des artistes algériens
jeunes
il n'aime pas qu'on dise 'on disons en
contemporain des artistes algériens qui
représente la scène artistique
algérienne aujourd'hui je les ai
rencontrés
disons que
à un peu un tournant de ma vie parce que
j'étais j'ai fait de la politique étant
de féministes comme comme vous l'avez
dit j'étais activistes on peut dire
aussi écrivaine ça j'espère que je le
suis toujours que j'aurai le temps de
reprendre de reprendre l'écriture mais
disons à un tournant parce que je me
suis réinstallé alger après une très
longue période à paris où j'ai passé 22
ans à l'unesco je m'occupais des
activités sur les femmes des droits des
femmes
et aujourd'hui on peut dire que sur le
plan politique le pays est au point mort
voilà pour pour aller vite s'il vous
voulez parce que j'ai pas tellement
envie de parler de politique
frontalement et je m'intéressais à la
politique parce que je m'intéressais à
la société parce que j'essayais de
comprendre la société algérienne dans
laquelle je vivais dans laquelle je
vivais et le discours politique comme le
discours militant féministe nommé des
plus nommé déplu à comprendre ce qui se
passait et nous étions arrivés à une
situation où un échec
il faut dire à des échecs que que je
n'arrivais pas à expliquer que je
n'arrivais pas à expliquer et j'ai
rencontré ces artistes ces jeunes
artistes algériens qui sont vraiment
dans le temps qu'ils sont dans la
réalité des choses et il
ils ont parlé un langage qui m'a tout de
suite séduite parce que c'était un
langage qui parlait de la créativité qui
parlait le langage que je trouvais plus
près de la réalité des choses plus près
de la réalité des choses
il disait il ils arrivaient à
transmettre des images de cette réalité
que le langage politique n'arrivait plus
à transmettre n'arrivait plus même
élaborée élaboré et donc je me suis
lancé dans cette aventure c'est une
aventure à mon âge qui est quand même
assez avancé je me suis lancé dans cette
aventure j'ai eu l'opportunité
financière d'acheter en plein centre
d'alger un très très grand lieu qui
était une friche urbaine une friche
urbaine qui fait 500 m² alors je sais
qu'ici nous prenons part c'est très
clair c'est très clair et si les photos
ça donne à peu près 5000 pieds carrés
bon mais quand même d'accord 5000 pieds
carrés et qui fait que j'ai acheté avec
l'idée de le mettre à la disposition des
artistes sans autre intervention de ma
part et il se trouvait que devant la
beauté du lieu qu'on a restauré et dans
lequel on a découvert une structure
absolument époustouflante puisque elle
le lieu et 7 un rez-de-chaussée d'un
grand immeuble des années 50 qui donne
sur une cour d'après quinze mille pieds
10 ans ou même plus peut-être trente
mille pieds non armes cours et on en le
on est en voulant le rénover on a
découvert on a mis à jour une structure
faite avec des poutres de la tour eiffel
et des poutres de la wii ce avec alger a
été longtemps à le gérer été longtemps
une colonie française et est donc
l'immeuble a été construit en 1950 et il
a été construit c'est de l' architecture
coloniale très belle architecture
coloniale et donc on a on a découvert
que c'était les poutres de des ateliers
eiffel qui avait servi de construction
de l'immeuble
du coup ça
lieux a pris une dimension historique
très importante où mes démons politiques
se sont réveillés évidemment parce que
c'était emblématique de choc de plomb
sur doux surtout c'est surtout et je
prends un peu de temps parce que c'est
une très longue histoire et surtout il
faut ajouter que les cantons eiffel a
mis en place ces ateliers pour faire ces
fameuses poutre qui sont particulières
je pas le terme technique exact il a
fait le tour des pays colonisés par la
france pour trouver les meilleurs la
meilleure le meilleur minerais et il
s'est arrêté sur une une veine enfin je
vois comment on appelle ça une mise une
mine dix ans une mine qui est un miliana
c'est-à-dire à 200 km d'alger
et si en disant que c'était le faire le
le milieu de meilleure qualité pas le
faire le minerai de meilleure qualité et
donc cette idée si vous voulez de ce
minerai qui est sorti des des mines de
miliana de 100 km d'alger qui va en
lorraine et qui revient sous forme de
poudre j'ai trouvé que c'était vraiment
quelque chose d'assez formidable et du
coup tout de suite quand j'ai vu le
chantier le chantier qui ressemblait
c'est vrai à une ville détruite et on
est en plein là dedans c'est c'la
malheureusement j'avais l'impression
d'être à alep c'est un quartier où j'ai
demandé à cinq artistes de mes amis de
venir et pendant trois semaines de
travailler pour faire pour faire
une exposition d'un jour et de détruire
tout le lendemain c'est ce qu'on a fait
ce qu'on avait d'ailleurs je suis très
contente de dire que l'ambassadrice du
canada est venu nous voir plusieurs fois
et qu'elle a été absolument enchantés
par ce qu'elle a vu et admiratif aussi
je crois que je peux le dire c'est
isabelle roy pense que si elle m'entend
elle dira pas non en tout cas là tout
était sur son sur son tweet comme bien
c'était comme et c'était beau et
important donc les ateliers sauvage
c'est un d'un centre de création
artistique dans lequel je reçois des
artistes
évidemment en majorité des artistes
algériens c'est facile à comprendre mais
aussi des artistes étrangers c'est tout
vert j'ai reçu déjà une artiste grecque
est une artiste allemande est une jeune
bédéiste allemande qui qui a fait un
travail absolument remarquable en un
mois et qui sort en septembre un livre
un poème graphique sur alger très très
grande qualité vraiment et cet espace
est cet atelier cet espace de création
ouvert
j'ai l'impression de façon vous le
décrivez c'est c'est tous azimuts un
créateur contemporain une créatrice
contemporaine un lieu créé c'est la
condition du vbc c'est à dire évidemment
vous savez quand on soit j'invite des
gens que je connais le travail que l'on
apprécié le travail ou sont des gens qui
me sollicitent avec d un dossier quoi
c'est à dire un portefeuille de fonds
après moi je me renseigne on se
rencontre etc mais aussi des écrivains
aussi des écrivains
j'ai créé liés aux ateliers sauvage une
bourse pour
l'écriture scénario une bourse à qui est
composé d'une somme assez importante
pour pouvoir vivre alger en tout cas
très confortable et une résidence d'un
mois aux ateliers
donc on peut être aussi aux ateliers et
résider écrire écrire mais c'est un lieu
qu'on peut partager parce que c'est
tellement grand oui y avoir plusieurs
artistes en même temps c'est important
pour vous de redonner cet espoir dans la
vie à alger dans un milieu en revenant
de se rendre de la grisaille parisienne
vers la alger la blanche
oui parce que
mais c'est pas une question de soleil un
sens qu intérieure
c'est pas une question de se laisser
vous savez quand j'ai écrit mon premier
livre qui s'appelle une éducation
algérienne mois qui a été publié par
gallimard
j'avais écrit ce livre parce que en
revenant d'elle en revenant à alger je
me disais nous
j'ai vécu alger tout le temps sauf
pendant ces 20 ans apparu à paris en 62
l'algérie est un pays pauvre
il ya eu pas de pétrole enfin le pétrole
était très bon marché c'est un pays
pauvre mais un pays plein d'espoir plein
d'espoir là n'est ce pas et j'ai ma vie
a été construite autour d'une utopie et
cette utopie c'est c'est c'est l'utopie
des années 70 que tout on a partagé son
évolution vers celle où son anniversaire
et je me disais mais ces jeunes n'ont
pas de d'utopie n'ont pas de désir non
pas de désir et je crois que ce qui est
intéressant dans les ateliers sauvage
d'abord il faut dire une chose très
concrètement et très prosaïquement si
vous voulez c'est que ça a été aussi une
opération de réapproprie se réapproprier
l'espace urbain qui est accaparée par
les vendeurs de pantalons et les
vendeurs de fast food à dire que la rue
d'alger n'est pas du tout une rue
culturel sais tu sais la rue de la
consommation consommation à outrance à
outrance et donc c'est je considère que
c'est une conquête une victoire d'avoir
pu arracher un espace de cette envergure
et de cette dans cette situation là
c'est à dire plein coeur d'alger c'est
vraiment c'est c'est la rue sainte
catherine
là où je suis c'est la rue didouche
c'est vraiment la rue de tous les
commerces de tous il à se réapproprier
un lieu pour en faire un lieu culturel
c'est assez formidable
en même temps mettre les
les artistes au centre de la ville au
coeur de la vie et je crois que ça c'est
très très important de les mettre au
coeur de la ville donc cette démarche
est elle d'abord jamal j'ai je suis
amoureuse d'alger amoureuse d'elle j'ai
c'est à dire que jamais alger malgré ses
défauts et il j'ai toujours et je vais
avec beaucoup d'algériens je partage
toujours ses blessures quand on voit
notre ville abîmé abîmées par le fric
abîmée par la pollution abîmé par
l'inculture abîmées par le mauvais goût
abîmé pas d'argent et donc le faire
quelque chose comme des ateliers en
plein alger
c'est vraiment une victoire c'est une
victoire quand j'ai présenté le projet
est une association de d'architectes m'a
demandé de venir leur présenter un peu
ma philosophie de du lieu la philosophie
dont deux de la restauration pourquoi
j'ai entrepris ça j'ai dit et après
avoir côtoyé maintenant un public parce
que maintenant il ya un public les
ateliers en leur public jeudi
je crois que j'ai donnée aux algérois un
objet de désir
c'est à dire ce qu'il ce qu'il ce qu'il
désire pour être ailleurs ce qu'il
désire d'ailleurs ce qu'ils envient à
lier c'est à dire dans ces villes comme
comme chez vous exemple dans si on va
mile end quand on va dans tous ses
quartiers qui sont vraiment restaurer ou
avec des lieux de culture des grands
lieux de culture même même des cafés
mais des cafés qui sont des cafés de
culture de trouver en pleine ville à
leur disposition dans leur ville sans
avoir à prendre un visa prendre l'avion
etc
c'est chez nous c'est fini aussi d'être
important oui
wassila tamzali est-ce que cet ailleurs
là aussi pourrait essaimer du nom d'une
certaine façon entre les ateliers
sauvage et à un autre lieu par exemple
lice
une collaboration qui peuvent se faire
absolument d'ailleurs je suis là pour ça
je suis venu pour ça
je suis venu pour ça parce que j'étais
sollicité invité par le festival arabe
du monde arabe qui va tenir
c'est ça sa session du 27 octobre au 7
novembre sur ce toit mais voilà et donc
quand la vice présidente du festival est
venu à alger et qu'elle a vu les lieux
elle m'a dit écoute c'est absolument
magnifique et voyant son enthousiasme je
dis est ce que tu penses qu'à une
opportunité de montrer les artistes
algériens à aman qu'à mourir
elle m'a dit oui donc je suis venu vous
voir des amis puisque c'est un peu les
vacances et l'été et et je suis
maintenant je suis contente de pouvoir
dire que j'ai trouvé une galerie c'est
la galerie mail tic qui est sur le
plateau mont-royal et nous allons je les
ateliers vont y exposer 4,5 g pas encore
il faut que j'arrête un peu le nombre et
l'exposition quatre cinq six artistes
algériens vont exposer du 28 octobre au
7 novembre
voilà qu'est ce qui fait que wazi data
nous à lire encore cette flamme ce feu
ne s'agissait pas vrai c'est ce que me
dit c'est tout le monde me dit ça mais
mais je pense que tout à l'heure je
disais l'utopie je pense que j'ai partie
de ces gens qui ont été marqués par une
utopie profonde et qui croient au
changement je pense que vous savez
gramsci disait j'ai le pessimisme de la
pensée et l'optimisme de l'action alors
il faut vous dire que souvent quand je
me lève le matin je suis un peu
désespéré parce que tout l'édifice
il vraiment c'est difficile alger de
faire des choses et mes mais j'agis je
suis dans l'action parce que je me dis
je fais partie de ces gens qui pensent
qu'ils peuvent changer le monde encore
je sais que c'est pas possible mais je
fais comme si c'était possible
donc je crois je crois l'extrême
vitalité de la vitalité de l'algérie qui
est un pays qui passe des moments
difficiles mais qui est un pays
extrêmement vivant survivants je dirais
qui a survécu à des drames énorme et
aujourd'hui je crois qu'il est très très
important pour nous venant de ces pays
là de dire que dans nos pays il n'ya pas
que les questions du terrorisme de
l'islam de nom il ya des hommes et des
femmes jeunes moins jeunes plus vieux
qui réfléchissent la condition humaine
qui réfléchissent à ce que c'est que le
monde qui ont envie de beauté qui
réfléchissent à la beauté et qui veulent
construire la beauté c'est ça que
j'aimerais dire venez voir il ya
aujourd'hui quand on est algérien on
n'est pas seulement immigrés on n'est
pas seulement réduit à
comme je dis parce que je me suis
beaucoup occupé de ces questions a reçu
c'est sa culture on est on est on est
dans dans l' aventure humaine on est
comme vous dans l'aventuré humaine et
moi je n'aime pas qu'on me réduise à une
culture ethnographique je déteste ça et
mes artistes les artistes avec qui je
travaille mes amis les jeunes artistes
que j'ai des tous sont vraiment des
artistes oui ils sont algériens parce
qu'ils ont d'alger mais c'est des
artistes universel il travaille nous
ramène à dépenser à des réflexions à des
problèmes à des as des as des questions
qui sont des questions de l'huma les
questions de l'homme les questions de
l'amour les questions de la beauté les
questions de la mémoire est question de
la même
question de la violence évidemment
puisque vous savez qu'on est dans un
monde très violent et plus on s'approche
du sud et plus c'est violent je sais
viola mais je vois quand je vois les
médias occidentaux sur notre nommons nos
sociétés on est vraiment réduits à des
ad je dirais pas stéréotypes parce que
c'est trop con c'est trop employés on
est réduit à des modèles on est réduit à
des modèles on devient des modèles
réduits voilà on est vraiment réduits à
des à des images avait les terroristes
les pauvres et il ya ces 500 m²
davanture vers le monde
multidimensionnelle daffé en plein coeur
d'alger
ça s'appelle des ateliers sauvage centre
d'art contemporain
wassila tamzali merci beaucoup d'être
passé et je vous souhaite un bon retour
cet automne avec quelques avril où vous
viendrez oui oui je reviens le 28 avec
une exposition à la galerie mal tic dans
le plateau au plateau ont dit au plateau
sur le plateau sur le plateau du mont
royal est donc je reviens avec cinq six
artistes contemporains des hommes et des
femmes algériens et algériennes pour
montrer comment
comment on vit un peu dans ces pays là
parce que vous faut il y a il ya une
abondance d'image mais l'abondance
images tu souvent la réalité des choses
pour leur dire voilà comment vie voilà
ce qu on est c
merci beaucoup d'être placé à part bonne
fin de ses jours